herzlich willkommen beim neuen video wir
gerade aufgestanden hat mir noch einen
blog anguckt und jetzt ist es 12.30 und
wir müssen uns ziemlich beeilen weil ich
jetzt los muss die pünktlichkeit auf
jeden fall schon mal nicht ja ich weiß
meine haare sind zu heftig aus der alte
heute geht es nach duisburg und zwar
bekommt mein auto einen etwas anderen
look also das ganze ist jetzt auch
nichts mehr das ist nur ich kann euch
sagen es wird böse meine haare sind
einfach schon wieder viel zu lange das
ja-wort machen kann deswegen gehen jetzt
wieder nach hinten so gut dass er mein
thema nicht sehen können das ist nun
nicht mehr geräumt alter und ich brauche
mein schönes outfit auch das passt ganz
gut es geht jetzt nach duisburg wo es
auf jeden fall seine zum friseur und
leute die das ganze so aus gut
geschlafen denn die mal zu gehen und
sich was zu holen ich tret von uhren und
hätten nicht
wir wollen ohne ball wolle mit dem benz
wurden mit dem geld
wollen uns so leute was geht wir sind
jetzt angekommen ich bin da schaut man
darüber dass steht schon leuchten das
irgendwie so geil ich freue mich mal
wenn ich andere autos hier genauso aus
wie mainz brot ist auch geil
wir steigen kurz aus und zwar schaut
euch mal das auto jetzt an die felgen
sind ja jetzt gerade noch silber und wir
schauen jetzt mal was wir ausmachen ist
gleich leute ich bin jetzt schon fertig
nein spass bin ich nicht ich muss jetzt
einfach drei stunden warten und hab mir
in der zwischenzeit ein neues auto hier
gekauft nicht spaß habe jetzt so
leihwagen und zwar ein nissan gt hug
warte hier gucken ist angeht nicht spaß
also dass es irgendwo eine
familienkutsche warte ich zeige euch das
mal okay ist sagte mappus
auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt folgendes
problem ich hatte eine gute kamera in
meinem auto vergessen
ich habe jetzt nur ein handy ich bin
jetzt nach oberhausen gefahren und zwar
kann man hier shoppen im centro der
heute hast du mir geld auf jeden fall
ein t shirt hier und haben ich war schon
mal im zentrum vor ungefähr mann war das
empfehlen weil dann mehr hatte ich in
meinen fantreffen mit ca sofort danach
wieder und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht da
hast du doch mal hier in die frage ist
wie komme ich jetzt da rein 6 1 1
stunden später findet zurück im auto des
autos fertig kannst jetzt abholen ich
bin mal gespannt und ja ich war ja
gerade ein bisschen hirnzentren
oberhausen unterwegs auch wenn ich mich
bestimmt fünfmal verlaufen habe es war
ganz cool was ich einmal gern sein würde
wenn ihr mich erkennt spreche mich bitte
sofort an ich mache mit jedem fotos gar
kein problem nur ich finds halt immer so
blöd und ich fühle mich dabei selber so
dürfen so beobachtet wenn man einem halt
hinterher rennt und das war halt heute
wieder zwei drei mal so also ich merke
dass mittlerweile fast immer wenn mich
jemand erkennt und denkt da nicht so
undercover hinter mir
es ist halt irgendwie echt immer noch
ein bisschen blöd also sofort ansprechen
und ich bin super lieb und jetzt schauen
wir mal wie mein auto aussieht ist
gleich so leute ich hab meine kamera
jetzt wieder
ich wollte euch noch einmal kurz zu
diesen boten muster zeigen und guckt
euch das mal an alte sind mega geil aus
und ich habe jetzt glaube ich fast die
gleichen folgen darauf die leute mega
cooles auto wegen jetzt meine maus
ich habe es wirklich noch nicht gesehen
das steht irgendwo dahinten ich zeige
euch das am besten man hier weil es ein
bisschen blöd hier ist ein parkplatz das
war ja cool aussehen sollte was geht
mein tag ich habe es gestern leider
nicht mehr geschafft weil es einfach zu
dunkel wurde und das waren wir ja
irgendwie zu schade für die aufnahme ich
bin jetzt hier einfach mal in köln deutz
ganz oben auf seinem coolen parkhaus ich
war schon öfter mal zehn jahren ist der
dom und da ist die lanxess arena
ich glaube das letzte mal war ich hier
vor ungefähr einem jahr oder so da haben
wir seinen 300.000 abonnenten special
gedreht und da habe ich nicht nur in
köln geboren und ich wusste zu dem
zeitpunkt auch nicht mal dass ich nach
köln ziehen werde behauptet dass sich
hier studieren werden oder sonst was
also hat sich ziemlich viel verändert
hat zwar eigentlich gar nichts mit
diesem video zu tun aber wollte ich
gerade mal sagen also 130 auf jeden fall
sagen das auto sie richtig böse aus also
mir gefällt es jetzt wirklich noch mal
viel viel besser als vorher
und ich würde sagen ich zeige euch das
jetzt machen
[Musik]
foto münsterland zu leute also sieht das
ganze jetzt aus sind halt jetzt schwarze
felgen kräften kommen aber ich muss
sagen es macht schon wieder was aus und
es sieht jetzt irgendwie aus wie ein
ganz anderes auto wenn wir es prüfen
lässt auf jeden fall meine daumen nach
oben da vielleicht auch wenn er öfter
mal videos von autos sehen wollt oder so
weil ich mich dafür ein letzter zeit
immer mehr interessierte gerne auf jeden
fall meinen daumen nach oben da lassen
und das in die kommentare schreiben
ich weiß dass jetzt die meisten von euch
das wahrscheinlich nicht so cool finden
aber wenn es 20 prozent sind recht ist
schon ihr seid ihr eigentlich die
anderen können dann von mir gewohnt und
ja das war's mit dem video zeigt auf
jeden fall snap jüngster gemacht ich
muss jetzt in die uni noch ein bisschen
lernen wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder
14 uhr einschalten
ich bin einfach gerade noch auf dem weg
zur uni und ich war so einfach durch
köln
ich kenne ihn gar nicht also kann ich
persönlich gar nicht aber ich glaube das
ist auch ein youtube auf jeden fall
krasser amg